Tu n'obtiendras rien de moi jeune homme
J'ai travaillé dur dans ma vie pour laisser quelqu'un...
Tu veux mourir ?!
Pas devant moi fils de p****
*musique de Superman*
*AU SECOURS! *
*Aidez-moi!!*
Est ce que Larry est là ?
Non? OK
Non dites lui juste que j'ai appelé, merci
*QUELQU'UN M'ENTEND?!*
*VOUS M'ENTENDEZ ??!!*
*AU SECOOOOUUUURS!!!!!*
*BANG*
Waouh, joli costume !
Ferme-la Stan Lee !
Oh m****
Ohh c'est pas bon
Non non non
Tu vas pas t'en tirer cette fois..
C'est affreux..
Je suis vraiment désolé
Je suis resté trop longtemps dans la cabine
Pour être honnête avec moi même j'aurais dû appeler le 911
Bon, plus rien de tout ça n'a d'importance maintenant
Parce que je pense qu'on oublie tout les deux le point le plus important
Qu'est-ce qu'une cabine téléphonique foutait au coin de la rue?
Elles ont pas disparu en 1998 ?
J'aurais pu juste utiliser mon portable
Une glace à la cerise
Tu as besoins de ça?
Ne réponds pas maintenant, juste.. repose toi
J'ai passé un coup de fil en fait
A mon couturier
Il s'appelle Larry, il m'aide à m'habiller
Je sais pas comment les autres héros font ça si rapidement
Tu serais probablement pas mort si c'était Logan (Wolverine) qui t'avais aidé
Qu'est ce qu'il a à enfiler lui ?
Il met juste un p***** de t-shirt, un jean
*imite Logan* "Je met mon petit t-shirt"
"Un peu de transpiration, une petite lute contre le crime, yeaaah"
Faisons des câlins à des Koala ("Happy Hug-A-Koala day")